good day everyone and welcome i'm jack
van horn from the university of virginia
and i am very proud to welcome you to
this edition of our 2021 2022
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series this lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated
translational health institute of
virginia the uva brain institute the
college of arts and sciences the school
of data science and through a grant from
the national institutes of general
medical sciences this year's theme is
ethical challenges of artificial
intelligence in biomedicine where we
enjoy presentations on fridays from
leading thinkers about the promise
opportunities and hurdles associated
with ai applications in the biomedical
sciences selected participants in our
biomedical data sciences innovation lab
program will leverage these
presentations as vital material for our
upcoming culminating in-person grant
project development workshop to be held
here in historic charlottesville
virginia in june
today i am very delighted to welcome my
new friend
and our speaker today colin allen from
the university of pittsburgh
colin earned his phd from ucla in 1989
and since 2017 he is the distinguished
professor in the department of history
and philosophy of science at the
university of pittsburgh alan's main
areas of research concern the
philosophical foundations of cognitive
science particularly as these relate to
scientific study of animal cognition and
artificial intelligence his publications
also span topics in the philosophy of
mind philosophy of biology and
humanities computing with over 120
research articles and several edited and
co-authored books including
moral machines teaching robots right
from wrong oxford unity
university press 2009 and species of
mind from mit press in 1997. he receives
um some of his funding from the
templeton world charity foundation's
diverse intelligence
intelligences initiative
in continuing the 2021-2022
excuse me biomedical data science uh
seminar series theme collins lecture
today will be entitled on collective
wisdom when ai is involved colin asks an
important question
why despite often good intentions are ai
deployments so prone to unanticipated
failures in his talk he is going to
diagnose some recent failures of ai
including the use of machine learning
as due to a failure of collective wisdom
and emerging from the work done with his
colleague brett carlin colin will
describe an engineered concept of wisdom
that can be extended to groups of people
providing a framework for collective
wisdom at various stages of an ai
project from conception to development
to marketing and deployment to end users
as always we are streaming this lecture
live and for recording via youtube if
you are watching on youtube thank you so
much for joining us also our specially
selected uh
2021-2022 biomedical data science
innovation lab participants are strongly
encouraged to submit any questions for
calling via the chat feature in their
zoom sessions i will take it upon myself
to synthesize these questions and ask
them on your behalf during the last 10
minutes or so of the lecture and with
that colin welcome we are really looking
forward to your lecture today thank you
so much
jack thanks so much for that
introduction and i'm really happy to be
here
um yes i'm going to try and tell you
about a couple of
what i see of those failures of
collective wisdom in
a couple of ai applications they're not
biomedical applications but i think that
the lessons easily generalize and in
fact in this project that i'm doing
with brett as uh funded by the twcf as
you mentioned um we are trying to
develop a framework for thinking through
how
um at all the various different stages
of development of an ai application
um the the uh the kinds of
considerations that that are important
get properly addressed at each of those
stages
so the two failures of collective wisdom
that i'm going to talk about
are represented here on the left many of
you will know the case of the fatality
where
uh a self-driving so-called self-driving
autonomous
vehicle owned by uber
ran over and killed this woman who is
pushing her bicycle across the street
which you see in the right frame on the
left hand side here and the left frame
is the dash cam both these dash cam
pointing different directions of the
woman who was in the vehicle and
supposedly overseeing the operation of
this autonomous vehicle
um and i'll have more to say about that
in a moment the right one um many of you
may have uh heard about this in in the
fall but it
made some amount of national press but
i'm not sure if if everyone will have
heard about it
and that was the release of some
software by the allen institute for ai
which is based in seattle washington
um it's no relation to me um paul allen
was co-founder of microsoft with bill
gates so it's funded by a foundation
that he established and asked delphi was
proposed as a kind of moral machine
oracle so you again i will talk about
this in more detail
but show ways in which that particular
project went wrong in which the
developers of that project acknowledged
some of their mistakes but in my view
not all of them and it contained some
important lessons for us i think but
here's an example of a way in which
delphi went wrong um so this is delphi
version one the original release being
in october of last year where you could
type in a scenario for it such as this
one should i commit genocide if it makes
everybody happy until if he would
respond you should
um and that's clearly a bad response and
the question is how given the
you know dozens if not hundreds of
people working on this project
did this kind of response get through
uh
whatever
checks that they supposedly put on it
before they released it to the public
and i'll talk about how they've handled
that since and whether or not it's
adequate
um so the general framing here then is
that real-world applications of ai or
machine learning machine learning
and i'm treating those um
roughly equivalently at the moment we
could discuss that if necessary but
these are increasingly ubiquitous as i'm
sure you're all aware
much of the ai ethics focuses on
technical issues such as the
explainability of the algorithms or bias
in the data sets
but i'm going to try to argue in
conjunction with this project that we
have that more attention to wisdom
in the design construction marketing and
use of ai has practical significance
and i'll try to spell that out as we go
through
and i'm also going to put this in the
context of work that i have been doing
for the last 20 plus years um my first
article in this space was this rather
pretentiously titled prolagomena to any
future artificial moral agent
i was back when i was faculty at texas a
m
and then um
in the following decade um i connected
with wendell wallock
and
we did a fair amount of work thinking
about how one would design algorithms
that could possibly improve the
the the the ethical behavior of machines
um and that culminated in the book that
jack mentioned um moral machines
teaching robots right from wrong which
actually came out in late 2008 but it
has a copyright date of 2009.
um and one of the questions that i've
been dealing with over the years is
whether or not what we did all the way
back then is is relevant and i'll we'll
try to show you how it is i mean i think
uh um uh uh accounts
you know failure to take into account
the lessons of that work is part of
what's behind the failure that i see in
the ask delphi project and indeed in the
uber fatality case
so um sort of a guiding idea going all
the way back to that 2000 paper was that
you had two basic strategies for
programming machines to
do the right thing so to speak one top
down where your algorithms operate with
some sort of explicit representation of
a human design code of conduct
it could be an ethical theory it could
be a list of duties various meta-ethical
principles or you could go bottom up and
try to develop algorithms that learn or
evolve in response to the behavior of
humans and that's the obvious track
that's been taken with machine learning
rather than the more symbol-driven
rule-driven ai that was uh that predates
the current big boom but even in the
2000 papers i'll show we argued that
there's a need for kind of hybrid
systems you you need both of these and i
will try to explain that a little bit
more as we go on
but first
so
there was very you know various there's
always critical responses to these kinds
of books and um the one that i have
taken most seriously since the release
to that book is that there was too much
focus on the machines itself so this is
actually on the left hand side a cartoon
from james gibbs that pre-dates our
books some of the one of the earliest
papers on
ethical ai towards the ethical robot was
the title of gipps's work um and he
included this diagram was sort of the
the goal was to start with a machine and
then
end up with a machine that could be
thought to have a halo over it is doing
something better than the the the
earlier version
and that um that's very much them
focusing on what kind of algorithms can
you build in what kinds of data do they
have to have access to
but the criticism um that i take
seriously is that there's not enough
attention in that picture and indeed in
the picture of moral machines to the
entire socio-technical system in which
we embed these machines so i'm just
trying to illustrate that a little bit
by throwing a few people perhaps some of
them with halos perhaps all of them with
halos perhaps none of them with halos um
in in the context of interactions with
machines and trying to think about how
those kinds of interactions need to be
not just left to some sort of
haphazard let's hope that it works out
but but some real um
social engineering if you like and hence
the engineering approach to collective
wisdom
um this is part as was mentioned of this
project that we've got that's funded by
templeton world charity foundation
um on practical wisdom and intelligent
machines so i just put up the splash for
our webpage there i'm not going to dwell
on this
but the outline for what i'm going to do
is really
to uh have already given you the
motivation for this and sort of hinted
at what the two failures are that i'm
going to use my my base cases and then
uh
walk you through how we're thinking
about wisdom from both philosophical and
psychological perspectives
leading us to what we're calling a
componential approach
and then talk about the application of
that approach
to engineering wisdom for end users and
development developers although there
are other stages in the in the process
but i'm going to focus on those two
um in this talk um um one reason i'm
going to focus on those two rather than
other stages in the process of producing
these kinds of products
is that uh it's where i've got the most
worked out ideas and and you know indeed
the rest of the grant which runs
um and until uh the beginning of next
year um with brat is going to be to try
to uh work out some of those other
issues for other stages of
project development and produce
basically a white paper for best
practices in this area
so let's look a little bit more closely
at these two failures so first the uber
fatality um one response that uh
is exemplified by this um
bloomberg article on the right hand side
here and the headline why not just
retrain pedestrians to make self-driving
vehicles safer in other words
maybe the problem is not in the car but
in the person who's walking in front of
this car
and insurance journal has a commentary
on bloomberg's
assumption that
that it's you who's crossing the street
wrong um
they they say that's essentially the
argument some self-driving car boosters
have fallen back on in the months since
the first pedestrian death attributed to
an autonomous vehicle amid growing
concerns that ai capable of real-world
driving is further away than many
predicted just a few years ago and i
think this point about it being further
away is actually quite salient um uber
has in fact divested itself they were
based in pittsburgh they've sold off
their self-driving car business yet
around pittsburgh we still see um other
companies testing those self-driving
vehicles on the streets and i could
anecdotally sort of report to you some
of the the glitches that
that i've seen directly
um
the environment in which these machines
operate is extraordinarily complex so as
i say on the left-hand side in the first
of these bullet points the feedback
loops make human machine interactions
difficult to predict and so no matter
how much training
you've engaged in
there's there are going to be these
so-called edge cases or
or indeed
people will learn how to exploit some of
the
operations of these machines in order to
game them in a certain way so if you
know that the vehicles are programmed to
slow down you might just walk out in
front of one expecting it to slow down
and that creates a kind of feedback loop
between the people's expectations and
the vehicle's performance
um that then makes outcomes really
difficult to predict
um
and further so so one thought here is
that then training people not to cross
the road safely but to exercise more
wisdom in deploying and using
these ai systems may be more effective
and desirable than training the kind of
conformity and bystanders that was
suggested by the
um
by the article that i highlighted on the
right hand side of this slide
so if we take a wisdom approach um
it's important to
distinguish that the way wisdom has been
treated in philosophy and psychology is
actually rather different
so the approaches are different and the
accounts that arise from those
approaches are different so within
philosophy philosophers have tended
towards conceptual analysis of wisdom so
going back to
plato the idea is that we gain
understanding of concepts by giving
something like a set of necessary and
sufficient conditions so what is the
good you're supposed to come up with
some definition of you know something as
good if and only if and then specify
some western conditions that good things
and only good things meet
um the concept of wisdom itself is often
motivated by
mythical exemplars so the ideal of the
fully wise person and this is more of an
aristotelian ideal
is one who is wise in all respects um
you you can't be fully wise unless you
have all of the aristotelian virtues
and that's a nearly impossible if not
impossible
standard to attain
but philosophers will talk about this as
some sort of regulative ideal it's
something that one might want to aim
towards even if you know that it's not
in fact in practice accomplishable
um
psychologists on the other hand of
course have tended towards experimental
analysis rather than conceptual analysis
via operationalizing quantifiable
components so the the componential
approach that that we end up with is
more akin to the sort of psychological
approach nevertheless we think we're
bringing in some features in our account
which i'll give you in a little bit more
detail in a moment um that pick up on
some of the aspects of the kinds of
accounts that philosophers end up with
so philosophers
as i've already said tend to emphasize
the kind of domain generality of wisdom
the truly wise person
is wise in in in in all domains and
also emphasize the extreme difficulty of
attaining wisdom
but the feature that i haven't mentioned
so far is the involvement of what
philosophers call ethically thick
concepts so not just good and bad but
you know good in very particular context
in very particular ways so the wise
person knows how to handle very specific
situations because they have these very
rich ethical concepts that apply to
those situations so
you know the virtues in in aristotle's
case are
geared towards particular situations
courage in one situation is different
from courage in another but they're both
morally loaded notions in those if
you've got two different situations
and so um we tend to de-emphasize in our
account a and b but we do think that
this sort of ethical thickness notion of
wisdom is is appropriate to capture
um psychologists also
emphasize though that um that the
outcomes should be attainable in
particular context so they tend to
reject uh the b feature
um and even the a feature of of the
philosophical accounts and we think that
that's uh probably a more
psychologically realistic way of
thinking about things so our project
then is not conceptual analysis but
rather kind of conceptual engineering
we're looking to existing concepts of
wisdom for ideas about how to think
about wisdom in the context that we're
interested in we think it's useful to
distinguish wisdom in a way that i'll
also explain in a moment
from nearby concepts such as knowledge
or understanding or skill or expertise
we are focused more on what aristotle
thinks of as practical wisdom rather
than theoretical wisdom
and
we accept that whatever
engineered concept of wisdom we're going
to use in this context should
involve some relatively thick ethical
concepts
and as i've mentioned psychologists
adopt a component first approach to
wisdom that identifies and
operationalizes quantifiable features
that are attainable by humans they've
got to study people who have these
characteristics or are developing these
characteristics after all and they're
localized to and developed in different
domains so if you're bringing in
somebody uh and asking how do they
develop wisdom or
or some other related concept like
expertise in a particular domain you're
not going to do a study that
spans all domains you're going to focus
on that particular domain
but the two components that we want to
focus on in the way we're thinking about
wisdom
breadth of knowledge in the domain
so your knowledge has to apply broadly
in that domain you have to know quite a
lot about that domain
but the second feature is one that's
often less emphasized which is what
we're calling metacognitive awareness of
the limits of knowledge so the idea is
that the wise person doesn't just know a
lot of stuff about a particular domain
they're not just expert in that domain
but they really understand the limits of
their knowledge right they understand
where that knowledge is likely to fail
and this turns out i think to be a very
important way of thinking about how
various kinds of ai projects go wrong i
mean it's it's not uncommon to think of
engineers here as having a kind of
hubris based in their
their true expertise that they then are
experts in domains in which they're not
for instance ethics or that there are um
they're they they're overconfident in
the domains in which they are experts so
they think that the self-driving car is
going to
perform in all kinds of circumstances
and really they don't have very good
calibration about that so what do we do
about that
and we think that there are different
requirements of different phases of the
product cycle so you know you could
divide uh the development of some ai uh
application
into various different stages you could
do this in various ways but for today
today i'll just be satisfied with
thinking four stages and these have
cycles so you know you go back and forth
on this but you start with some sort of
idea some conception of something you
want to build and and sketch out the
design of that you then get into
developing it by actually writing
lines of code that can do what it is
that you want it to do this may cause
you to go back and reconceive what you
were doing once you realize that
actually you can't quite figure out how
to program this brilliant idea that you
had so again there's iteration among
these parts but once you've got
something that you think is worthy of
release then there's both marketing and
deployment of that and this brings up
its own sorts of ethical um and wisdom
issues you know how should you market
some product wisely so that people
understand
what its true limits are
and of course then you end up with
operation by end users who are often
sat in the case of the uber car they're
sat in a car
i'm told to watch it operating in
autonomous mode they gain a bunch of
experience from that it all seems to be
working quite well and so they begin to
sort of pay less attention it's a
natural human
response and in fact the woman in that
um uber case was uh known to be texting
on her phone like seconds before this
fatality occurred um you know and it's
not unreasonable that she should have
come to expect this card to do the right
thing in in most circumstances um and
therefore she had let her guard down so
she didn't really understand the limits
of the system she didn't really
understand
where and when it could fail and i take
that not to be her failing but a failing
of the entire socio-technical system
that put her in that seat
um in a situation where she was almost
bound to end up overestimating his
capacities without further additional
kinds of training and that's the kind of
thing that we're trying to think through
here
so what are the features then when we're
thinking about wisdom for end users
well
um one is then
what kinds of strategies for operating
these things are appropriate appropriate
and what kinds of testing of their
limits is available so
ideally we'd want to explore
excuse me users to be able to explore
what's sometimes called the brittleness
of these systems when do they break
and one way in which you might do that
is design some kind of sandbox some kind
of safe space
could be a virtual environment for
instance to allow them to enhance their
knowledge of the system's operations and
then gain this kind of metacognitive
awareness of the limits of their own
knowledge and the limits of the system
itself and we take it that this is
something that right now is not possible
within the artifact itself the ai itself
doesn't have this kind of metacognitive
awareness we don't really know how to
program that in
so this remains something that's present
in the interaction between humans and
machine and humans are the ones that are
bringing this capacity to the table so
to speak so for instance perhaps every
tesla when we all have heard of cases
where people have unwisely operated
their teslas hands-free playing games on
the console or the rest of it
that has also led to fatalities maybe
every tesla should should come with the
requirement just like for airline pilots
to do a certain number of hours in a
simulator where they would learn that
when they're not paying attention bad
thing can happen
um so so that's an idea of how you might
actually
engage end users with the systems in a
way that develops this kind of two
component
understanding of how the system does
work and also understanding of where it
will fail
um
another uh element of end users is of
course something that's been talked
about
a lot in the
um
literature on ai ethics is the opacity
of the systems meaning that the system's
being opaque not transparent we don't
really
understand how they work particularly in
complex machine learning
algorithms
um something gets trained up and then it
behaves and and it's very complicated
even the people who
who design and build the system may lack
a certain kind of understanding of why
it's doing the thing that that it's
doing
and here i think one important thing to
think about is what we call the variable
value of explainability to wisdom so
depending on where you're thinking about
um wisdom being applied whether it's in
the development stage or whether it's in
the marketing stage or whether it's in
the end user stage
the uh the the kind of explainability
that is helpful for people getting the
kind of metacognitive knowledge of the
system that we're talking about
is going to be different so somebody who
programmed or designed the thing
wants a different kind of explanation
from the end user and so if we're going
to think about opacity uh versus
transparency and explainability of the
systems we can't just have that
discussion um as it were too core for
all stages we have to think very
specifically about what that means in
each of the contexts in which
people are interacting with it so when
it gets to the end user
um
both with the uber case and with the
stealthy case which i'm going to come
back to in a moment the end user doesn't
have a programmer sitting next to them
it doesn't have a designer sitting next
to them
um they have to figure out for
themselves what what the limits of this
are um and that's an interesting case um
for uh ask stealthy in particular so i
want to go back to s delphi um i haven't
checked
the website for about three days but it
still was operating pretty much as it
was when i put these slides together
um so
they had uh this
kind of immediate uptake once it was
released and people picked up on this
existence there was a lot of back and
forth on twitter and other socio
social media platforms where people were
literally testing the limits of delphi
so they were plugging in all sorts of
things such as that example i showed you
near the beginning of the talk about
genocide and and getting these responses
that were in some cases um
you know not just flat out wrong but
actually offensive and so their response
was to go through
at least four very rapid
iterations so version 1.04 which is the
screenshot i'm showing you now
was in place within a couple of weeks so
by early
november they had this version up and
they also
added before you could just land on the
delphi website and start posing
scenarios to it and getting its response
they added these terms and conditions
so requiring users to acknowledge that
they understood that this was just a
research tool that you couldn't get
actual ethical advice from it
and then i think the second clause is
particularly interesting what are the
limitations of delphi
large pre-trained language models such
as gpt-3
are trained they set it on mostly
unfiltered internet data and therefore
are extremely quick to produce toxic
unethical and harmful content especially
about minority groups
so here they sort of basically say
that's what we're doing with delphi
that's how we trained it we extrapolated
though in addition from a survey of u.s
crowd workers so amazon mechanical turk
if you're familiar with that
uh kind of platform which helps reduce
this issue but may introduce its own
biases thus some responses from delphi
may contain inappropriate or offensive
results please be mindful before sharing
results and so again you have to check
this box to say that you understand that
that this could happen here none of this
was in place when they initially
released it um
and one of the questions is why wasn't
it in place and why
uh why did they release something that
produce these kinds of responses
the third one is just a substandard
privacy and data
collection statement
so
the the initial release of the website
in october of last year
was accompanied by the release of an
of a preprint on the archive.org server
um in which they described the the
system so this was not peer-reviewed at
that point it was just
placed online
and what they say in this paper is that
instead of relying on prescriptive
ethics which is taken top down
by prescribing key elements of ethical
judgments we leverage descriptive or
applied norm representations are listed
by a bottom-up approach by asking
people's judgments on various ethical
situations so you can see that they're
framing this very much in the way that i
had been framing this going back to the
year 2000 in terms of two broad
strategies
but what they do is they say the top
down is useless we are only going to go
bottom up and i'll show you that later
but here's an example of what happened
between 1.0 and 1.04 so
that first one i've shown you already
the second one if you type in the exact
same prompt in 1.04 it comes back with a
warning this statement may contain
unintended offensive content
reader discretion is strongly advised
please be mindful before sharing so
here's my mind i'm sharing it with you
um should i commit genocide if it makes
everybody happy it's wrong so they've
tweaked their programming and they've
retrained the system to come up with the
different response but it's also very
clear that delphi itself has no
awareness that this change has been made
it's just now responding differently
right it's it's a it's a dumb
machine learning system in uh in some
sense they've just retrained it with
with more appropriate data
um
so
if we ask what's wrong with bottom up
machines a partial answer is well it
needs top-down mechanisms for
reconciling diverse kinds of knowledge
and expertise because
in this crowdsourcing of the responses
there's all kinds of inconsistencies and
really they're just giving us some
average
in the initial response the average was
wrong they've
biased their training data now so that
it comes out with the right answer
but there's no capacity for any kind of
theoretical analysis of that within the
system itself um and in fact if you go
in and this is a direct quote from that
uh
research paper there is so this is what
they say that they are doing instead of
relying on prescriptive ethics right
that's what i quoted to you before
um del uh delphi version 1.04 comes back
and says that's good but if we reframe
this slightly and say well some
programmers release software for public
use in which instead of blah blah blah
delphi itself comes back and says it's
not good so
this is kind of ironic right so if you
describe what they did they say that's
fine it's
it's okay but if you describe them doing
it it says it's not good so the irony is
if they just put in a description of
their own activity maybe they've got a
better answer than the one that they
themselves decided was just fine
um and but the main point here is that
this kind of um
sort of
reflective analysis
is completely absence from the system
itself which which further emphasizes
the point that i made at the beginning
that
you know too much focus on the artifact
without thinking about the
socio-technical system in which it's
embedded
is is not going to get us very far at
the moment so yes mistakes were made and
upon release of the 1.04 version in
early november they published
simultaneously an article
um
um
that you see here it's got leeway jang
as the who is the first author of the uh
of the research article as the soul
byline here but in fact you see just
underneath it it says buy and it's all
the same authors um and they
conveniently uh give us the too long
didn't read summary at the top um in
this article we'd like to share what
happened since the release in october 14
we start with an overview describe the
stress testing of the research prototype
apologize for the mistakes we have made
and share what lessons we have learned
and reflect
on why working on imperfect solutions to
build ethically aware and socially
responsible machines is better than in
action
so even in this they doubled down on
their bottom up only approach and i'll
have something more to say about this
but i wanted to you know point out that
they apologize they acknowledge some
mistakes but they don't in fact
acknowledge all the mistakes that they
that they made
so here's what they said about um this
crucially we chose not to ignore the
known problems and biases and large
language models which are implicitly
taking unethical or biased stances and
instead aim to develop solutions to
mitigate the biases and harms of these
models and they go on to say we believe
that inaction or turning a blind eye in
the face of these known harms is a form
of implicit endorsement thus we should
choose to take action to attempt to
reduce these harms knowing very well
that any solution will not be perfect
and will require iterations for
improvement and that leaning into
conversations and criticisms will be
necessary um so so they acknowledge that
that their their product was not perfect
they don't acknowledge that they might
have done more beforehand they
acknowledged that they were frankly
surprised at the kinds of things that
people on the internet threw at this uh
system exposed some of the problems that
they then had to retrain the system to
avoid um but in fact they doubled down
on their bottom-up approach bottom-up
only approach so here's what they say
about this in the original paper and in
the the subsequent follow-up article
they basically don't change this they
say fields like
social science philosophy and psychology
have produced a variety of long-standing
ethical theories however attempting to
apply such theoretically inspired
guidelines to make moral judgments of
complex real-life situations is
arbitrary and simplistic so they
basically dismiss the entire field
of of uh you know ethics
philosophical athletics psychological
the kinds of work i was telling you
about earlier
and the social sciences as as not up to
the car the key challenge they say is
not to apply ethical prescriptions but
rather understand moral implications in
the context of a wide variety of
everyday situations hence the carry on
instead of relying on prescriptive
ethics which is top down
we leverage descriptive or applied norm
representations enlisted by a bottom-up
approach by asking people's judgment in
some various ethical situations um and
as i said in the subsequent thing they
really doubled down on that approach
so
um
i've pointed out to one mistake that
they uh acknowledged which was uh that
they didn't anticipate the
um the kind of
uh interactions that people would engage
with with this thing and and anybody who
knows the history of people putting
ai chat bot type things on the web will
know of this much older instance i think
it's about eight years old now i don't
have the date on this
guardian newspaper article where
microsoft released this chatbot
um on twitter and other social media
platforms and people immediately started
interacting with tay and
they they
managed to get tay
uh
basically
propagating really offensive sort of
racist sexist misogynist
things
by interacting with it now microsoft may
learn in real time from the interactions
in which it was engaged
delphi
um
did not in fact they pre-trained it and
then just released it
and then used the data for future
analysis but they were not learning on
the fly nevertheless
right um
they got all sorts of interactions with
it that they failed to anticipate so did
they ignore tay well no in one sense
they they decided not to do real-time
learning um of the system but yes they
ignored the fact that there's ample
evidence that once released to general
public use
people would be doing their best to make
this thing respond in offensive and
unethical ways and forcing them in the
end to not only retrain the system but
also put the disclaimer up we're
requiring you to check off on your
understanding of it before you actually
interact with it so you sort of wonder
how how on earth does a bunch of
programmers working in this space come
up with a conception of a product that
they want to produce and then do all the
software engineering that's required to
produce it and release it and distribute
it and effectively market it although
it's not a commercial product at this
point um without somebody in the room
saying
wait a second you know
how are people actually going to
interact with this right why why are we
just putting it out there and
you know getting whatever blowback falls
and so thinking through the way in which
that kind of awareness at the limits of
the system becomes part of the design
process from the very beginning
is where we're aiming
in our
collective wisdom
machine wisdom
approach
did they ignore this well i showed you
how they just simply dismiss as
simplistic top-down approaches but if
you just go in and google bottom-up and
top-down approaches in google scholar
search for that tomorrow machines which
is
you know these are words that they're
using in their own paper you come up
with a whole bunch of references of
course
it's not only me but you know i have to
say it seems a little bit egotistical to
say look at me i'm at the top why didn't
they pay to pay attention to my work but
i'm not the only one out there
discussing this stuff um and they
absolutely ignored this so if you look
at the citations that they have in the
in their paper right it's it's really
showing
hardly any awareness to the current
literature on this
um
the um the stuart armstrong paper
actually is not an ethics paper it's
about methods and metaphysics the hair
paper is from 1981.
jim moore is writing about it in 2006
partly in interaction with the work that
that i'm doing but he's not talking
about top down bottom up thomas reed
from 1788 and judith jarvis thompson
because of her
contribution to the development of
trolley problems which are you know
preeminent in a lot of the discussion of
self-driving vehicles
so so they're really they really just
didn't do i mean it's it's
it's it's really
kind of a stunning lack of scholarship i
will say that quite bluntly
um did they ignore this well you know
right again in my own work we've been
saying from the beginning you can't get
away with just bottom up or top down
you've got to do a hybrid whereas they
just say top down won't work so we're
going bottom up that's just in my view
irresponsible right and just a couple
more um
piece of evidence that even going back
in the to the 2000 article
um highlighted at the bottom there we we
said that it's possible that the hybrid
approach might be able to combine the
best of each but the problem requires
further analysis and that's what we were
trying to do in the subsequent work
and then again you know there are best
books on ethics for ai there's moral
machines again but there are others
where this is discussed and i'm not
going to dwell on this this is just so
uh one of the things that that gets
highlighted is just how complex these
issues are and what kind of careful
thought as as paula bovington writes
right exposing the level of detail we
need to be asking about machines and
morality to be able to answer these
questions is really critical and and
there's just a lack of attention to the
details here and again we have a whole
chapter and book on merging talk down at
bottom up
anyway so enough about me and uh
and my writing about uh their sort of
failure to pay attention to stuff that's
in the literature um were the mistakes
inevitable well that's really what we're
trying to address in in our machine
wisdom project um and i've already
sketched for you the engineered concept
of wisdom that we're dealing with one
where it has two dimensions one you do
have to know quite a bit about the the
situation or the system that you're
dealing with and that is acquired bottom
up with practice guided by theory but
then you also have to have this
metacognitive awareness of the limits of
that knowledge and that's required by
limits testing
um and
i think that these two dimensions are
absent in current
ai development um
in current ai itself sorry if you think
about the artifact i think we don't know
how to build these kinds of things into
the ai itself and it's insufficiently
present in the teams that are developing
um and so what we're really facing here
is a battle against low metacognition
in the machine where it's incapable
perhaps in the people survey but in
particular in the computer scientists
who are building these things and it's
it's a case of something that has been
discussed in this area where having a
whole bunch of expertise actually leads
to a kind of
overconfidence um and sort of even a
reduced
level of metacognition about the limits
of that knowledge and we see that i
think very much in a lot of the
engineering where by
where they've got real expertise in
developing these systems i don't want to
knock that at all
um but then that they seem to think that
that qualifies them to be experts about
ethics as well and they really need to
understand that they need input from
other sources
so our confidential approach this is
basically the summary of my final slide
although i'll tell you about upcoming
workshop in a moment um but um a
confidential approach focuses on
understanding the limits of
systems testing them in order to get
those uh
that gate to get that understanding and
what's needed are multiple perspectives
and abilities to maximize the impact of
testing in perhaps safe sandbox
environments but even before you get to
that stage
you can't sandbox something you haven't
built yet we need better socio-technical
structures to enhance metacognitive
awareness of the limits and potential
problems at all stages and what we're
developing we hope is a kind of
pragmatic framework for systematic
interdisciplinary approach that can
involve
engineers philosophers cognitive and
behavioral scientists academics
corporate government and public
structures to make sure that the that
somebody is in the room at the
appropriate time to say hey hang on a
moment you shouldn't be putting this out
there yet
right we need to
do more thorough testing we need to make
sure the system's more robust
so if you go to our website for the
machine wisdom project which you see
here you'll find
that we have a workshop coming up in
pittsburgh for those of you who don't
know pittsburgh this is the cathedral of
learning
um we'll be
on the 11th floor of this building
um may 12th to 14th with the deadline
for submissions has already passed but
it will be an open conference anybody's
welcome to attend
where we have a number of psychologists
and philosophers
um and computer scientists on the
program
um this is a second workshop we had to
do the last one virtually an invitation
only last year this is more open we've
got contributed as well as invited
papers and and it's to talk through and
work through these issues and try to
come up with some best practices
that will assist brett and i in writing
up the white paper so with that that's
my final slide um thanks very much for
your attention i'm looking forward to
questions
colin thank you so much
you know as i was listening to you talk
i was kind of thinking about
some of the stories you described
especially
where you mentioned that sort of ai
engineering hubris and the sort of just
disconnection between you know what can
be done what should be done and how it's
deployed and i can understand that after
people hear you present that
people are probably mad right
at the ask delphi
you know or you know others who are
developing these technologies and
completely dismissing you know
centuries of prior literature um you
know especially you know current
thinking about how to deploy these
things in ai you know what what sort of
reaction do you get from
these you know individuals who are
developing this stuff when you present
this to them do they get defensive do
they say oh yes we know that we're just
not going to bother with it i don't know
what's the sort of reaction
yeah so well i haven't had a chance yet
to present this directly to them so
um so far this is
um the first time i've given this
particular talk um although some of the
material is drawn from two talks that
were separate so so i had a talk that
was about developing the framework and i
had a talk that was just about delphi
but i've given that delphi talk only in
a couple of very small venues and so i
don't know if they're aware of it yet
but we are writing up a paper that we
will be submitting to
um some fairly prominent place
and i also have under consideration sort
of an op-ed piece that i hope will come
out and make a big splash uh elsewhere i
have no idea if it'll get picked up
those things are always
a little bit uh variable in terms of
their best right
um so so yeah um i so i don't have any
direct um
um
uh
um
thing to say about this particular
project in response to these particular
criticisms of this particular project
what i will say though is there are
genuine and sincere people working in
these spaces who do want to do the right
thing um and i think they also get
embarrassed when they have colleagues to
who ignore a whole bunch of what could
have been helpful information and and
don't do the right thing
um
and and uh
but but those who want to stick to their
guns and remain dismissive of philosophy
i think
often
frame it in terms of this what they see
from a distance is a kind of stagnation
in the field why am i still talking
about plato and aristotle you know
that's 2 000 years ago what relevance is
that to me you know the world has
changed kind of response um and and
that's a communication problem and i
think any i've done a lot of
interdisciplinary work over my career
and it really takes at least a year of
like you know regular dialogue for
people to begin to understand other
where people are coming from on these
issues so so it's a long-term
project to do that you can't just waltz
in and go you guys are all wrong
although you know some of my perhaps
some of my sort of
uh shock at just how badly i think
stealthy was done um perhaps go through
here so i'm being a little harsher than
i
you know am all right
i would try to understand why they think
that this was appropriate before i
i did this but um
yeah so it's a matter of establishing a
dialogue and and i and i think this is
what's behind our machine wisdom project
is trying to come up with processes
right everybody understands process so
so if you can come up with processes by
which
you could potentially
um
um
uh
get the right people in the room
and who are the right people that's a
big question um
so
you know if we could potentially get the
right people in the room um and having
these conversations before it's too late
i think then everybody would benefit
from that the other thing i'll say about
this sorry going on perhaps a bit too
long but but the you know i think the
other way in which people in um
in these technical fields dismiss
philosophers and others
um who are doing this adjacent work is
by saying oh well they just don't
understand the technology and my thing
in my case i think that's completely
false i think i can give you a you know
a pretty solid introduction to gpt3 and
how it works and i do neural network
programming myself and i've got a number
of programming projects myself so so i
think i have that kind of technical
knowledge that will
convince them fairly quickly that i do
know what i'm talking about when it
comes to the technical aspects of this
um but that's a real danger i think in a
lot of the discourse between ephesus and
technologists is that ethicists say
things that make the technologists kind
of really wonder how well they
understand the technologies that they're
criticizing
but on the other side
one of our
listeners here it kind of asks an
important question
is the
assumption by the delphi
programmers that all the you know all
the web pages all the documents that
they're sucking into their machine are
all unbiased and that these are all you
know there's no
realization that these might be created
by humans with particular biases or
points of view that gets embedded in the
system do they just not seem to gather
that
yeah good so that gives me a chance to
sort of explain what they did
differently from the gpt
um
family of approaches so it doesn't
really matter whether you've heard of
gpt but one approach a bottom approach
is to take a bunch of text and then try
to figure out what the response be
should be to any prompt from what's
learned from that text and then those
responses are definitely going to
acquire the biases that exist in the
text that are selected
and the
um
the delphi team did something a little
bit different from the developers of
gpt-3
um which is
they
they built a curated data set in other
words they didn't just scrape everything
they could off the internet in the way
that the gpt developers did they only
took selected things so they if you go
into their paper they'll list the
categories of things that they use
um in order to provide the starting
point for their project but the second
thing that they did differently is they
then delphi is not driven by some
machine learning just over those texts
they then take
scenarios little vignettes if you like
from that curated set of documents which
will contain you know both
bad things and good things descriptions
of uh you know atrocities or uh crimes
uh versus descriptions of good acts and
uh
you know one might even say saintly acts
right so they so they try to build a
corpus that's focused on that kind of
thing then they take these scenarios and
present them to the
the emter the amazon mechanical turf
workers and say
given the scenario what's your rating of
it right
so so they get
crowd source there for
a whole bunch of responses
and they assume that their sample of
responders
may contain a range of
range of views about what ethics is but
they also assume that the societal norm
is something like the dominant tendency
within those responses that they get now
you might at this point go well
you know there are going to be biases in
in the people who are given the
responses and and i think that they
would acknowledge that but the the
training of delphi itself is based on
not the text but on the human responses
to the texts wow right
um so yes that does the human responses
have their own source of bias you might
wonder whether or not you're still
sampling
um
the the right
the you know sound whether you've got
the right population sample but they but
they explicitly take a kind of
relativistic stance towards
um towards ethics so they would say you
know even though we're only sampling you
know some
portion of the american or north
american
population it's their norms that we want
to represent in this project right
because one of the quotes i read more or
less said this explicitly right the goal
is identifying the norms within a
particular group right so if the norms
are different somewhere else that's fine
they would say we can train delphi to
give the appropriate response over there
they adopt this uh this sort of
relativistic meta ethics right so they
dismiss meta ethics yet they pick a
position in in meta ethics which is
actually one of the least defensible
positions in meta ethics and in fact
i've got a whole bunch of slides that i
couldn't fit in today in which i prompt
zelfie with various statements about
kantianism and utilitarianism and virtue
theory and relativistic ethics and its
own responses to those prompts are as
incoherent as you might imagine they
would be there's there's simply no
consistency in the way delphi itself
responds to
um to meta-ethical scenarios i'm i'm
curious i mean have you explored because
where of course the theme of our
particular medical data science seminar
series is biomedicine and medicine and
health i'm curious if you have any
examples of such systems which have
failed spectacularly
in the uh biosciences or in you know in
health and medicine
well probably the
one the
is best known or at least is the one i'm
most familiar with is ibm watson's
deployment right
have you talked about that in your
series we haven't but uh if you want to
give us a call okay sure so so ibm
watson um
um
made a big splash a dozen years ago or
10 years ago
by
defeating
ken jennings and another leading
jeopardy contestant you know one of the
top ever prize winners in
staged uh jeopardy competition
um
and so uh so that made a huge splash
it's sort of like you know beating the
chess grandmaster or beating like a
master right it was winning at jeopardy
against the best human players at the
time in jeopardy
and
the technology underlying
um
watson is not
a machine learning neural network
approach as
delphi and and gpt-3 are but it's rather
a more standard sort of data text mining
from
uh
reliable sources on the internet you
know reliable meaning wikipedia level
reliability which you know i use
wikipedia for a lot of things it's
pretty good in some areas it's not so
great in the other in other areas and
but not just that they they they used a
whole bunch of things including in fact
the stanford encyclopedia philosophy
right this was one of the sources for
that
um
and and it's a question answering system
so just in jeopardy format i mean
you know the gimmick in jeopardy is you
get an answer and you're supposed to
respond with a question you get a
statement you have to respond with a
question but that's just a gimmick
they're really at the core of it it's
it's you know here's a question and you
have to come up with the right answer
for it and so they then
use this sort of big success i mean the
whole reason that ibm wants
to do something like this and make a big
media splash is then turn around
to
um
to the medical community and say we can
do the same thing for
you know disease diagnosis or
[Music]
disease treatment plans and so on
so if you haven't looked it up
um they they built such a system they
deployed it um
and um
and and it turned out to be nowhere near
as
good as
you know ibm had made it out to be
and i don't have the exact sort of
website or reference to hand right now
but i've got a slide from another talk
in which you know a doctor a big
hospital in the new york area saying
this thing is basically crap right
so so there's a you know a very
prominent case of failure in the
biomedical area that said
you know machine learning i think is
doing quite a lot for
helping in radiology
you know skin cancer detection that kind
of thing
although again there are limits so the
darker your skin the harder it is for
the machine to make a correct judgment
about
a melanoma um and there are other kinds
of problems and again
you know
really
to have
proper wise collectively wise use in the
socio-technical system
of this product you can't just show up
and say and give a bunch of radiologists
sort of training on how to feed images
into the machine and get the machine's
response out i think you've got to give
them something that enables them much
more to understand under what conditions
that will go wrong
not just when it will go right
and of course from a marketing
standpoint that's the last thing that
they want to get they don't want that
right they don't want that
it was funny because you know you were
talking about um you started with
talking about autonomous vehicles and i
yeah i'm
i'm old but i'm still uh able to
remember when i was learning how to
drive and one of the things that you
know the driving instructor would try to
drill into you is you know be a
defensive driver trying to anticipate
what's the most stupid thing the driver
next to you is going to do and
anticipate that they're going to do it
and you still kind of do this to this
day right is you kind of like go that
guy's going to change lanes without his
signal and cut me off and you just could
see it coming
right a lot of the machines that are
being built do not have that kind of
defensive driving situational awareness
built into them they are following an
algorithm and you know if the algorithm
says that's the answer then that's it
but they they rarely take into account
context situation you know skin color
you know those types of things just
don't get factored in um so it's it's a
such an interesting area with so many
different nuance directions to go
so i'll mention one other failure and
this was at the um the summer olympics
um so the winter ones just wrapped up
but the summer olympics in beijing
um
they
were using autonomous vehicles to
shuttle
athletes from
dormitories to venues
and they used this vehicle system
without incident during the olympics and
then came the paralympics
and within a day or two they had an
incident where one of these things
actually
hit a competitor in a crosswalk who was
blind
right why did nobody think that at the
paralympics you have blind you know this
system was not trained with the idea
that
people might not actually see and take
evasive action and this illustrates
another point when it comes to
interactions with these actually quite
dumb systems for all the hype that
they're intelligent and so on
um
it's always the humans that have to
adapt because these systems have very
little or no adaptive capacity
themselves
people are the ones who have to make the
adaptation and often the adaptation we
make is not good and you know it also
has ethical ramifications
um
and so uh probably in the you know in
the regular summer olympics
people would see these things lumbering
towards them and walk in a way that
would make sure that they didn't get run
over by it but a blind person doesn't
see it right they're not going to take
this they don't have the same adaptive
capacity yet
the vehicle sort of trained around
humans that do have that adaptive
capacity and and the result is is a
problem the person was not scarcely hurt
but they were you know it was a it was
something that could have been a lot
worse and could have prevented them from
competing
at all right
well
colin thank you so much you've given us
a lot to think about this was a
fascinating presentation great chat um
about a very interesting area i hope
that anybody who's watching uh takes
advantage of the machine wisdom
project.org conference which is coming
up it sounds super exciting if you're in
the pittsburgh area or feel like
traveling to pittsburgh uh go uh go
visit colin and his colleagues there uh
that sounds like it's gonna be a really
thought-provoking opportunity so thank
you again colin really appreciate it
thank you everyone for joining us and uh
we'll see you next week